this now is former Massachusetts
Democratic governor that's Duval Patrick
former aides to President Obama
encouraged him to run for the Democratic
nomination this year wonder how he feels
about that now or ask him just a sec he
has said no citing quote the cruelty of
our elections process and how it could
affect his loved ones
Patrick is now managing director at the
investment firm at Bain Capital from
what we hear doing very well but right
now he's joining us at the table good to
see you good morning good morning
Patrick we'll talk about your regrets or
non regrets a little bit later but let's
talk about the exchange between Connell
Harrison and Senator Biden yes how
critical do you think it was for both of
their campaigns well you know it's a
moment and it certainly was a dramatic
one they would I would I appreciated
about it and what I think struck so many
is how how personal senator Harris was
in describing the issue and the impact
on her and her her family I think she
was also quite respectful of the vice
president's record on civil rights and
and and discrimination generally I know
them both and I agree with Senator
Harris that that Vice President Biden is
not a is not a racist I was surprised
about how awkward or uncomfortable he
seemed in answering the question because
he's answered the question many many
times over many years I thought he
should have been better prepared because
he's certainly knew that he it was
coming yeah well I suppose that's that's
true and you know it's hard to be
prepared for for everything but the fact
is and we were talking about this a
little bit before coming on camera there
are lots of progressive Democrats and
and liberal minded people who are
uncomfortable with busing and were at
the time and I think one of the reasons
for that having been involved in some of
these issues and in Prior lives is that
in many respects we said the kids in to
do what the adults wouldn't do we sent
the kids in to integrate the schools
because the adults wouldn't integrate
the neighborhood yeah and sooner or
later we are going to have to confront
the bigger question about the importance
of learning to live in integrated life
the importance of that for the survival
of our democracy and the success of our
society and the question is where do you
learn that in school in the neighborhood
in the university and in so many areas
that's been under attack are you
satisfied with with Vice President
Biden's answer on the bus in question
and the way he responded about
segregationist senators well I don't
think his answer last night was as good
as the answer he has as a sort of a
performance matter again okay
I think his comments that were quoted
from them I think it was a fundraiser
about working with segregationist
senators may have been a little a little
too much given the time and given the
but I think the point he was making is
if you if you want to get the things
done in in Washington you have to be
willing to work with people who don't
agree with you on everything yep and you
know they're there there is a value in a
politics politics that says we can work
together on some things without having
to agree on everything you know a thing
or two about health care as governor the
model for Obamacare was actually
implemented in Massachusetts given what
you know do you think this
medicare-for-all idea can work
politically or practically well I have
to tell you Tony I kind of hear
medicare-for-all as a as an
all-encompassing slogan meaning it it
captures in in an oversimplified way in
some respects a lot of different nuance
among the candidates in the campaign's
personally I think the idea of Medicare
being available for everybody is a
fabulous idea the idea of Medicare being
required for everybody is something I'm
less warm to what struck you about the
difference between the two debates
because I know you know many of the
candidates who were up there on the
podium what struck you well first of all
I was I was struck by what I have always
sense which is that we have a remarkably
rich and talented field of candidates it
doesn't bother me one bit that there are
a lot of them you wish you were there
the possibility you could beat all of
them that's not how I was thinking about
it although when I was thinking about it
many months ago one of the questions was
how do you break through in a field this
large and this talented without being a
celebrity or or sensationalist and I'm
none of those things nights what did you
what sir I thought that the
first night one contrast has jumped out
was that they didn't speak about the
incumbent president should they and at
the second night they did a live long
and frankly you know and I think I may
be in a minority in this respect I don't
think Democrats should spend their time
on on President Trump it's not it I
don't say that as a matter of disrespect
yeah the the the impact and the and
frankly in my view the hurt and harm
that the president has done in the
nation is a matter of record that is not
what is going to win the election for
Democrats but will win the election for
Democrats is a positive alternative
agenda that speaks to how things will be
different not just how we will remove
the incumbent and go back to the way we
used to do things would be another
reason for you to get in the race
Governor Patrick no regrets on the
record well Patrick thank you so much